the kovat 19 pandemic is thought to have
started in a market in Wuhan but the
virus almost certainly has his origins
in bats the mammals host more than 500
different corona viruses and antibody
studies have shown that several have
been transmitted to people living near
colonies but if so far failed to spread
further scientists warn the next
pandemic will come from animals and
destruction of wildlife habitat is
making it more likely have been
increasing so then the academic
community is turn its attention to well
why is that you know and as two-thirds
of all human infectious diseases are
from animals then there's likely
something to do with how we're changing
ecosystems and changing the climate that
changes those infectious disease
patterns deforestation is the biggest
cause of habitat loss land cleared in
the Amazon for cattle ranches crops and
mining was 64 percent higher in April
than the same time last year
but palm oil used in many brands on
supermarket shelves in the UK is also
resulting any great swathe of forests
being burnt or felled we set the timer
for the next pandemic if we don't start
to tackle some of the root causes which
includes deforestation illegal wildlife
trade but also intensive agriculture and
ultimately what's at the heart of this
is that humans are being brought ever
closer into contact with wildlife and
its exploitation and this is where we're
seeing the rise of infectious diseases
Ebola Lassa fever and bird flu have all
spread from animals conservation groups
warned that world leaders must respond
to the kovat 19 pandemic by protecting
nature for the future health of humanity
Thomas More Sky News